well then take it away by Anthony Davis
Clark couldn't get it it's a turnover
and McCollum
gave it up for Damian Lillard Lillard
[Applause]
Anthony Davis kept it away from I mean a
good job without fouling ad put it off
his foot go Lillard and take it away
gonna be Lillard don't compounded man
points off the takeaway Alexia's Jensen
once again who had surgery on these
things
it'll be each one more take it away by
Lillard on the strip and it's going to
be a loose ball foul on more offensive
ass baby step
off the heel picked up by Damian Lillard
[Applause]
Malaya and Lillard on the rough in the
baseline nobody at home after he beat
narratives free heritage Tom begins a
college who just came into the game how
about he in Clarks triple really short
man picked up by Lily Belle's in Hajduk
pass from Solomon Hill almost threw that
away
Diallo and Augustin decision that he was
that wide open as he released it a great
look on the baseline from Ted Petrie
shattered it'll be Lillard got another
layup told me you would necessarily call
it a fun game to coach it was kind of
stressful but it was a definitely a fun
way to win yeah you know and they got
clutch plays like that the squad he
become a better three-point shooter
Darius Miller is a 35% er off his career
but as you pointed out 42% Damian
Lillard those are the kind of box outs
and feel like so good the ball bounces
on the floor
Damian swings it to Newark trying to get
him go a beautiful little jump shot as
the Pels had that triple Darius Miller
but they're looking at the last one and
loads going to get into the lay up out
of it points in the paint it's only two
a plus 2 for the pals now but last 3216
second chance points pals raids and
hopping on the move each one more denied
from behind good challenge there for 90
seconds how do they finish take it the
bomb Honolulu 10 but that's the spot
where being arrested me
we know that three years in a row right
here
Easter Sunday 5 o'clock tip hopefully
you can make it out against Oklahoma
City Lillard and step back he's 9 not
too good is now off the nerdkit he's
gonna get it back and rolls it home
again almost from the holster but got
him all the way to the hole out of the
timeout I scream from Miller's 3 Lillard
saves it so a B is 1 2 check back at the
games try to keep it within him and
urkesh
it's funny and now that he's injured he
gets the first first time he gets on the
floor yet he has a scoring opportunity
lady was there but it flipped over to
the other side 71-64 step back levered
[Applause]
[Music]
now Darius Miller
top three Lillard on the run and blocked
away from behind by Anthony Davis AK
Palin's from behind then let that go
because he had the ball on his
fingertips but all of a sudden it was
gone
leather man it's the catalyst though
Lillard 21 for Damian Lillard and boy
out of his 10 mates
you got to believe about eight of our
layups or behind a wall tough break in
and out only a three-point lead 90
seconds left in the third
so right answer is between these two
drew holiday up against liver and that
is going to be critical matchup
Lillard leaping into a triple one-point
game a second triple he's got 24 and
it's give it away
Napier with Willard and on the run a
lead to Portland
once I turnovers now at 80 on the floor
Lillard as they set the stack of top
real high for his step back he's on
[Applause]
[Music]
Dillons up to 28 gets the pin gentleman
shot boxer Napier mid-range Japan's
maybe recover without idea coming up big
off the bench but this is the guy you
worry about gonna be a little far away
Scott a little game doesn't
[Music]
[Applause]
waiting Lillard deep three unbelievable
over a deal sound of Anil on the dime
lovers already got 12 poppies 33 in the
fourth
make it 14
[Applause]
Internet to work with that much
[Applause]
though the taking wasn't it yeah I
thought Drew had a shot off the glass
and each one probably had a jumper off
two three ball dick after he wanted to
go over the back side good he'll control
it yes
Darius Miller now Lillard sets it up for
wide open up in Turner
and on the least initially second chance
parts of Killa the palace
health rate to nothing in second chance
points now Lillard sets it up for wide
open up internal long one
second chance ports of Kenneth apalis
house were eight to nothing in second
chance points